y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y el común una maestra la contadora una
camarilla
una empleada física y una médica
no todas ellas son mujeres y por lo
tanto vienen las desigualdades del mundo
del trabajo
seguramente todas quienes tienen algún
tipo de apoyo por lo menos una vez en la
vida y además todas ellas se encuentran
el empleo que se verán revolucionados
con las nuevas tecnologías
la agenda de genio está avanzando en el
mundo pero aún nos queda muchísimo
trabajo por hacer
todavía tenemos que explicar qué es ser
feminista afortunadamente cada vez somos
más las mujeres y hombres que trabajamos
por la igualdad de derechos y
oportunidades que es el feminismo
pero así todos hay números que dicen que
todavía nos faltan más de 100 años para
lograr la igualdad de género
principalmente dada por el mundo del
trabajo
y eso no podemos permitirlo porque al
mismo tiempo que sucede esto estamos
viendo los primeros avances de la
revolución tecnológica
que promete cambiar el punto del empleo
en unos 15 ó 20 años
la pregunta es
y si aprovechamos la revolución
tecnológica para potenciar la revolución
feminista
la revolución feminista avanza pero lo
hace linealmente
la revolución tecnológica crece de forma
exponencial
y si encontramos ese punto en donde se
unen ambas revoluciones
y vemos de potenciar la lucha de las
mujeres con la tecnología
los avances de esta revolución
tecnológica lo vamos viendo en nuestro
día a día y se van incorporando en
nuestra vida cotidiana casi sin darnos
cuenta
hace un tiempo cuando hacíamos un viaje
llevábamos mapas hoy tenemos una o más
aplicaciones para decirnos dónde estamos
y cómo llegar
seguramente muchos de ustedes hayan
hecho un pedido de libre o una compra
interactuando con voz como si fueran
humanos
nuestras líneas y niños utilizan youtube
para entretenerse dejan doblamos la
televisión abierta que están perdiendo
audiencia con plataformas como netflix
que se están metiendo en nuestro hogar o
como google que vino a desplazar taxis y
remises
probablemente conozcan a alguien que
estudió una intervención quirúrgica en
la cual se utilizó una robótica o una
prótesis impresa con tecnología 3d
vamos a asustarnos cuando leemos estos
titulares a la vista que nos dicen que
15 o 20 años van a desaparecer nuestros
empleos o que los robots van a
desplazarnos a nosotros
hoy vamos a ponernos a trabajar ahora
mismo para ese futuro
según los especialistas entre las
profesiones que más vivirán afectadas
por la inteligencia artificial y la
robótica se encuentran trabajadoras
agrícolas secretarias asistentes
camareras cocineras una larga lista de
profesiones en las cuales en las muchas
de ellas las mujeres somos casualidad
pero la inteligencia artificial y la
robótica aún no logran evitar unas
cuantas habilidades humanas como son la
empatía la comunicación la colaboración
o la creatividad
junto a la inteligencia artificial y la
robótica están avanzando otras varias
tecnologías como vida de 6
nanotecnología biotecnología internet de
las cosas la industria 4.0 y varias más
y estas necesitan no solamente
profesionales de la ingeniería la
ciencia y la tecnología sino que se
necesitan profesionales de todas las
áreas y principalmente mujeres porque
necesitamos la mirada diversa en este
mundo tecnológico que hoy sigue siendo
dominado por los hombres
en estas industrias tecnológicas se
encuentran trabajando personas
innovadoras de la sociología la biología
psicología y otras tantas área de las
humanidades la industria 4.0 no
solamente requerirá profesionales que
programas y administrar los entornos
tecnológicos sino que se necesitarán
profesionales de todas las industrias
los chain que seguramente lo escucharon
nombrar por la triste moneda de coin
además de eso se utiliza como una
plataforma segura para registrar
transacciones jurídicas inmobiliarias
educativas comerciales entre varias
otras
la impresión 3d y 4d junto a la
nanotecnología que hasta hace un tiempo
nos parecían presurosas hoy se emplean
desde la industria atómica hasta la
textil pasando por la medicina la
arquitectura y la decoración
el mundo del trabajo que se viene
requiere habilidades que las máquinas no
pueden realizar como son la creatividad
la innovación el pensamiento crítico y
algunas relaciones interpersonales y las
mujeres somos muy buenas en todo esto
entonces qué hacemos para aprovechar la
revolución tecnológica para achicar las
brechas de género
tenemos que trabajar para seguir
llevando mujeres a la ciencia la
tecnología y la ingeniería que somos muy
pocas
con programas
y rompiendo los estereotipos de la
infancia que son principalmente los que
hacen que la sufriendo elijamos esas
tareas pero además tenemos que pensar en
las mujeres adultas que hoy se
encuentran trabajando y seguirán
plenamente activas en el mercado laboral
en unos 15 ó 20 años
no tuvimos materias como programación y
robótica y nos van a ganar los
conocimientos necesarios hoy
si observamos el alumnado universitario
repentino podemos observar el 45 por
ciento de las mujeres
elige carreras relacionadas con las
ciencias sociales y jurídicas
un 34% se inclina por otras carreras en
el área de las ciencias de la salud
solamente un 7 por ciento elige
computación o ingeniería y un 4% ciencia
el mundo del empleo que se viene a
añadir a la tecnología como transversal
en todas las profesiones en cielos
entonces si la mujer no está haciendo la
tecnología aunque no le llevamos
tecnología la pujada
la medicina que como vimos es una de las
áreas donde la mayoría somos mujeres se
verán fuertemente afectadas por la
revolución
con robots haciendo diagnósticos con
porcentajes de efectividad en
enfermedades muy altos otros que
realizan cirugías planos robots que se
introducen en las arterias y otros que
encuentran y eliminan células
cancerígenas
la extranjería otra de las áreas
mayormente para por mujeres se verá
afectada por la reducción de los tiempos
de internación a través de dispositivos
de internación en los hogares y otros
avances
la educación un área en la que las
mujeres somos la gran mayoría pero claro
está dominada liderada por hombres
también seguirán afectadas para
adaptarse al gobernado que cada día es
más tecnológico
lo mismo sucederá con la psicología
en donde lo ustedes están siendo
digitalizados
las teleconsultas cada días más
frecuentes y los nuevos trastornos
existen derivados de la utilización de
la tecnología y las nuevas formas de
comunicación y de trabajo
los emprendimientos tecnológicos también
necesitan la mirada femenina
solamente un 10% de los emprendimientos
tecnológicos son liderados por nosotras
y es en donde más inversión hay
y el empleo doméstico también sufrirá
estas consecuencias ya que la robótica
doméstica y la tecnología aplicada
reducirá las necesidades de empleo ésta
es casi en su totalidad ocupado
tenemos que evolucionar hacia la
transformación digital de la mujer
y cuando hablamos de transformación
digital no estamos hablando de
digitalizar digitalizar es incorporar
tecnología transformar digitalmente es
llevar la tecnología es capacitar para
adoptarla en los trabajos actuales
y transformación digital no es
obviamente tecnología sino que son
personas
y en este caso en particular mujeres que
son las que sufrimos principalmente las
desigualdades del mundo laboral con la
brecha salarial los techos y paredes de
cristal que hacen que no podamos avanzar
a las posiciones de liderazgo de las
grandes empresas
si nos ponemos a trabajar ahora podemos
lograr un mundo laboral más igualitario
solamente tenemos que encontrar ese
punto
donde se unen ambas revoluciones
pero como sé que es esto
tenemos que crear e implementar
programas de transformación y
capacitación digital para mujeres y esto
no significa que los hombres no deban
capacitarse también plan que sí
pero para lograr la igualdad del trabajo
necesaria es imperativo trabajar con las
mujeres necesitamos empoderar y
capacitarlas para el nuevo mundo del
trabajo
y estos programas de capacitación tienen
que incluir técnicas para promover y
potenciar la creatividad innovación la
comunicación y la colaboración una
introducción a todas las nuevas
tecnologías el futuro de cada una de las
especialidades sean medicina enfermería
educación o cual fuere y además crear
programas de reconversión laboral para
aquellas que ustedes en línea ordinaria
que son las más propensas a desaparecer
y si comenzamos ahora a trabajar e
implementar programas de capacitación
digital para mujeres podemos tener en
unos 15 años
mujeres ocupando el 50 por ciento de los
empleos mejor para vos liderar como
mínimo la mitad de las empresas más
importantes generar modelos de liderazgo
femenino para las nuevas generaciones y
contribuir a una mejor economía más
igualitaria que resultaran beneficios
para toda la humanidad
y cuando alguien nos diga que el futuro
que se viene es uno sin empleo nosotras
les vamos a mostrar un futuro repleto de
oportunidades porque a partir de hoy
vamos a investigar a capacitarlos a
cobrar la voz y a trabajar para que se
realicen estos programas de capacitación
digital para
si hacemos esto podremos lograr un mundo
laboral más igualitario en el futuro
nos parece sencillo pero lo mismo los
ligeros con el voto femenino y algunos
nos están diciendo ahora con el aborto
legal yo estoy convencida que la
revolución de las mujeres por favor de
que cualquier revolución
incluso la tecnológica
porque nosotras generamos nuestra propia
energía renovable inagotable es la
seguridad y que cuando estamos juntas y
luchamos con nuestros derechos
nada ni nadie nos puede parar
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]